Ya
ben bir şeyler anlatırken
önce tanım yapmayı seven bir insanım
Çünkü yaptığım tanımlarla anlattığım
şeyin hem çerçevesini çizmiş oluyorum
hem de kullandığım kelimelerin her iki
taraf için de aynı anlamı taşıdığından
emin olduğum için genelde tanımlarla
başladım bugünkü toplantımızın ana
teması kazanana kadar Kaybet olduğu için
burada iki tane tanıma ihtiyaç var biri
kazanmak diğeri de kaybetmek şimdi tanım
yapmak dediğimiz zaman eve kazanmak
Kaybetmek hepinizin hemen hemen aklında
bir takım şeyler canlanıyordu zihinde
ancak sözlükte yer alacak şekilde tanım
yapın dediğim zaman bu biraz zor Yani
şöyle söyleyeyim hayatı boyunca hiç Spor
maç alakası seyret Memiş hiç bir yarışa
katılmış parayla hiç işi olmamış Bir
uzaylı geldiğini düşünün buna kazanmayı
anlatacaksınız kavramları kullanmadan
gerçekten zor iş Aynı şey kaybetmek için
de geçer Bu kaybetmek nedir diye Şimdi
soracak olsam
Story düşünün zamanımız yok o yüzden
sizin cihazınız duymak isterdim ama ben
12 tanım yapacağım kaybetmekten değil de
işte birkaç tane açılımı var Bunlardan
bir tanesi şöyle söyleyebiliriz sahip
olduğumuz ya da varlığından haberdar
olduğumuz herhangi bir şeyin konumunu
artık bilmemek diyebiliriz örneğimiz
anahtarını kaybettim nerede olduğunu
bilmiyorum ve suç benim kaybettim Ya da
cep telefonum kayboldu Cep telefonumu
nerede olduğunu bilmiyorum ama Suç benim
değil telefonumun Çünkü o kayboldu yada
birisi onu aldı alan kişi suçlu o
arkadaşlar şimdi buradaydı nereye
kayboldular dediğinde ortada su çok
arkadaşlarım nerede olduğunu bilmiyorum
ama onlar Nerede olduğunu biliyor ya da
buraya gelirken koridorda kayboldum Ben
Yolumu bulamadım geriye böyle kayıp
gidiyor Başka kayıplar var Ne var Maçı
kaybetmek Spor müsabakasına kazanamamak
veya hiç biraz önce da kaybettik dedik
ya bir yakınınızı kaybetmek pek artık
yanınızda değil bu dünyada değil Ortada
suç yok veya O işte çok para kaybettik
dediğinizde Elinizde bir miktar para
vardı artık o para yok nereye gittiğini
de biliyorsunuz ya da bilmiyorsunuz ama
yok şu kaybetmek genellikle olumsuz
anlamlarla eşleştirilen bir durum var
Hiç mi olumlu tarafı yok var Örneğin
Elimde bir yara izi vardı kayboldu iki
ay çarşıda kayboldu Ne güzel ya
daha acılar zaman içerisinde kaybolur
süper yok oluyorlar ya da
ya Dün akşam bana gittik kendimizi
kaybettik acayip eğlendik dediğimizde
gene harika bir kaybolur bunlar güzel
bırak bizim bugünkü ana temamız da
kazanana kadar Kaybet kısmında
kaybetmenin içerisinde sanki bunu
hiçbirisi yok da biraz başarısızlık
varmış gibi duruyor başarısızlık deyince
tabii başka bir tanım gerekiyor başarı
bugün çok çatlayacağınız şeylerden biri
başarıyı tanımlayalım ortalama Öncelikle
örnek vereyim isterseniz Mesela şöyle
şeyler kullanıp çok başarılı işadamı
yani çok parası var çok başarılı bir
sporcu yani çok Kupası var çok başarılı
müzisyen albümleri çok satıyor var
mesela Aleyna Tilki
milyonlarca tıklanma alıyor ve satılıyor
en fazla satan daha başarılı bir
müzisyen ben Niye çünkü 10'luk en fazla
60 günlerde ya yüzbinler de geziyor
Umarım konuşmayı Sayın Fazıl Say
dinlemiyor Dur şu anda Tabi şimdi Başar
a harfi bir ortamda ele aldığınız zaman
böyle garip yerlere gidiyoruz aynı cümle
içerisinde Aleyna Tilki ve fazla sayı
kullanabiliyorsunuz bu durumda başarı
için ve izafi şeyler ya da ona göre Buna
göre ya da sonuçla kıyaslanan bir şey
olarak değil de gerçek elle tutulan
gerçekten yine elle tutulan net tanımlar
yapmamız gerekirse bana göre başarı
hedeflenen bir noktaya hedeflenen
zamanda varmaktır Örneğin İki sene
içerisinde Şampiyonlar Ligi'nde final
oynayacağım dediği zaman birtakım Eğer
iki sene içerisinde final ederse
kazansın ya da kaybetsin başarılır
dördüncü senede kupaya Aslı bile
başarısızdır Neden Çünkü iki sene
içerisinde bir hedef koymuş klavye
ulaşamamıştır şimdi bu zaman süre
konulduğu zaman bir süreç var demektir
ve sürecin içerisindeki her şey tolere
edilebilir Bunun içerisinde kaybetmek de
var ama toplumlar çok fazla töleranslı
yapılar değildir asla toplumlar
dediğimde kalabalıklar dayım Çünkü
toplum deyince böyle bir sistemde bir
şeyler var Medeni leşmiş bireylerden
oluşan bir sistem var ama kalabalıklar
dersek daha doğru çok fazla tedavi
etmezler Özellikle de sonuçları
yargılarlar süreçleri de domine ederler
kalabalıklar
basma kalıp ifadeleri vardır ve bir
hiçbir işe yaramayan hiçbir yerde yazılı
olmayan kimin uydurduğu da belli olmayan
ve ilk fırsatta da kendilerini
uymayacağı kuralları vardır
kalabalıkların ve sürekli sonuçlarla
ilgilendikleri için çok sevdiği bir
durum vardır kalabalıkların O da
kaybetmek Birisi bir şey kaybetmeye
görsün hemen tavsiye vermeye nasihat
vermeye başlarlar Aslında Bak şöyle
yapacaksın falan diye başlarlar Peki sen
ne yaptın diye sorduğunda hiç hocam
hiçtir Ama hayatta olabilecek her
durumla ilgili fikirleri vardır böyle
bir anda kayıpla ilgili bir şey
gördüklerini içlerinden Birce da çıkar
ve nasihat vermeye başlar Ben senin
yerinde olsam şöyle yapardım diye
başlarlar gene sen benim O da Aynısını
yapardım arkadaşlar Hayatınız boyunca
ben senin yerinde olsam diye bir cümle
kurmayın böyle başlamayın hiç bir cümle
çünkü Eğer bir şey gerçekleşmişse o
gerçekleşebilecek en iyi şey olduğu için
gerçekleşmiştir yani o koşullar altında
O yetişme tarzına o geçmişte O anki
heveslerle o sonucu herkes aynı sonucu
verecektir başka bir şey olmaz Onun için
ben seninle olsaydım lafı kadar saçma
bir ifade başlangıç olamaz ama her
birimiz Çok Farklıyız hepimiz başka alt
yapılardan geldik Her birimiz başka
yetişme tarzıyla başka heveslere sahibiz
doğal olarak her birimiz aynı olaylar
karşısında farklı sonuçlar elde ediyoruz
farklı sonuçlar gelişiyor ama ben senin
yanında olsaydım kısmı değil bu
farklılık çok önemli insan olmanın en
temel şeyi romey yaratma cesareti isimli
kitabında şöyle söyler Bir insan ancak
kendi verdiği kararlar ve bu kararların
arkasında durduğu zaman insan olurlar
çok önemli bu ve bunu destekleyecek bir
başka şey de Benjamin Franklin şöyle
söyler eğer herkes aynı şeyi düşünüyorsa
kimse hiçbir şey düşünmüyor demektir der
gerçekten de bir Eğer hepiniz aynı şeyi
yapıyor olsaydık gerçekten düşünmüyor
olacaktık burada düşünme kısmı çok
önemli farklı farklı düşünmeleri çok
önemli Çok sevdiğim bir canlı türü var
bir deniz üzümü diye bir canlı
Bayılıyorum ben buna bir yumuşak Cansu
da yaşıyor denizde yaşıyor Bülent
onlarla besleniyor fakat Kendisi de
lezzetli olduğu için birçok balık onu
yemeyi seviyor bu Deniz üzümü
arkadaşımız hayatının ortalarına kadar
kısa bir ömür var ama ömrünü ortalarına
kadar kendine güvenli bir yer aramakla
geçiyor ömrü ve sorunda midyelerin
arasında kendine güvenli bir yer
bulduğunda oraya yerleşiyor ve bir daha
hiç Yiyecek arayan Kendi beynini yemeye
başlıyor Çünkü artık herhangi bir
arayışa girmesine düşünmesine gerek yok
beynini yiyor bu bana biraz tanıdık
geliyor
Ama artık güvenli bir yer güvenli bir iş
bir yer bulduğunda düşünmeyi bırakıp
kendisi için daha önceden düşünülmüş
lirasına insanları çağrıştırıyor halbuki
böyle değil de bizim varlığımızın temel
işaretlerinden biri düşünmekte Descartes
cogito Ergo Sum dediğinde yani
düşünüyorum Öyle sabahın dediğinde böyle
böyle indi gibi derinlere da düşmekten
bahsetmiyor du
düşüncelerimizi ifade ederken heyecan
larımız olaylar karşısında verdiğimiz
tepkiler beklentileriniz aldığımız
kararlar aldığımız kararların sonucuna
katlanırsınız ve onunla ilgili
verdiğimiz mücadelelerin sonucunda
ortaya çıkan bir tavırdan bahsediyordu
Bu Tavır Çok önemli çünkü bu sürekli bir
ileriye doğru gidiş olmak zorunda değil
Einstein der ki bazı kayıplar için
kaybetmek kazanma yolunda sürekli
kazançlar gerçekten de böyle bu bir
langırt oyunu gibi de topu sürekli
ileriye doğru attığımız bir şey değil
mücadele ediyor yeri adımda var bile
bile kaybetme de var bu kaybetmenin
tabii böyle çok renkli zevkli tarafları
yok Hepimiz bir şeyler kaybetmişiz
benden önce Üstadımız dairemiz Murat Bey
söyledi O da kaybetmiş kaybetmek doğal
ama hoş değil birşeyleri kaybettiğimiz
zaman Dünya böyle büzüşür bütün ya
götümüze doğru gelir yaşamak istemeyiz o
an hiç hatırlamak istemez ama sürekli
oynat Uğurcuğum diye biri vardır ve
sürekli olan hatırlarız sürekli o
kaybettiğimiz koşullar aklımıza gelir
nefret bir durumdur sonra bir süre sonra
bu kaybettiğimiz duruma alıştığımız da
döner dünyaya bir bakarız ki binanın
şarkısındaki gibi Aslında her şey
normale devam etmektedir yani akıp
gitmesi gereken her şeyi akıp
gitmektedir ve hatta bizim bu
kaybettiğimizde o akışın normal bir
parçasıdır tüm normal lerden bir tane
normaldir ve ben bu kadar böyle
anlatıyorum ama bu kadar basit değil
oy
kaybetmeye katlanmak bununla başa çıkmak
zor şey ve ben de size zaten
kaybettiğimiz zaman Üzülmeyin demiyorum
bugün bu oturumların devamını da size
bir sürü kaybetme hikayesi anlatılacak
edisondan Dayı sana bir sürü sporcu
sanatçı örnekleri bulacaksınız ben hiç
örnek anlatmayacağım ve ben Üzülmeyin
edemiyorum tam tersi üzülün diyorum
hatta çok üzüldüm kaybettiğiniz zaman O
kadar üzüldüm ki her şeyden nefret edin
dünya yok olsun isteyin ancak o zaman
zaten bir şeyler değişmeye başlar Yani
artık katlanamıyorum bu dünyaya
Dediğiniz zaman bir şeyleri değiştirme
zorunluluğu başlar ve devlet iyi olman
der ki bir beynin en yaratıcı olduğu
zaman konforu riske alışılmış ı sürprize
tercih ettiği zamandır lar şimdi Biraz
önce de söylendi aynı sebeplerden farklı
sonuç beklemek aptallıktır Yani aynı
sebepler hangi koşullar varsa aynı
sonucu ortaya çıkar her şeyde kayıp
Varsa bunun ya sebeplerini ya süreçteki
bazı koşulları değiştirmek gerekir ki
sonuç yani kayıp değilsin Böylece
yaratıcılığınızı kullanmaya başlarsanız
Ben yaratıcılığa inanmama yani
aklınızı kullanmaya koşulları
değiştirmeye başlarsınız ve dünya
değişir tabi Burada bir iş var ve hem
Hiç daha önce denenmemiş bir şey
deneyeceğim hem de sonucundan Emin
olacağım diye bir dünya yok Tekrar
kaybetmek de var ve olabilir bir şey 1.1
cümlenin bittiği zaman ya da bir şey
bittiği zaman konulan bir işarettir ama
kaybetmek olduğu zaman konulan bir
işaret değildir vazgeçmenin sonunda
konulan bir işarettir nokta kaybetmekten
sonra virgül gelir ve kocaman bir günler
gelir her bir virgül yeni bir ümittir
Yeni Bir enerjidir yeni bir girişimdir
çok gençsiniz hepiniz hepinizi çok
ineceğiz ve yani kaybetmek bu işin bir
tarafı dedim ya bir
tatsız sevmiyoruz
kaybedenlere de kaybettiklerimize de
tahammülümüz azmaz ama
bu her birimiz çok değerlisiniz
gerçekten öyle Her Birimiz Ayrı ayrı bı
kendince değerleri sevgilisi ve önem
taşıyan yönleri var Her birimiz
birbirimizden Çok Farklıyız ama farklı
olmayan bir şey var O da şu sonucunda
her bir arzu duyurulduğu zaman başka bir
arzuyu mecbur kılacak böyle
var ya Benim yapacağım bir şey yok her
bir Kazancınız başka kazançları mecbur
kılacak Sonu gelmeyen data hiç
uygulanmayan bir mide gibi düşünün bunu
sonu gelmeyecek ancak kazanç larımızı
neyle ölçeceğiz büyüklüklerini
küçüklerin ölçeceğiz dersek kazancın
sanki ölçütü yaz mutluluk gibi ne kadar
mutlu ettiğine bağlı mutluluğun pek
ölçüsüne Bu mutluluğun ölçüsünü de sanki
kaybettiklerimize gösterdiğimiz tahammül
gibi algılayabiliriz
bursla güvenli bir yazar
barder ki 20'li yaşların ızla bir gün ya
herkes gibi olmayı ya da
farklılıklarımızı Erdem'e çevirmeyi
tercih edersiniz ler bugün bu söylediğin
şey çok fazla şey anlam ifade etme
olabilir sizin için ama çok fazla şey
düşündür melli Çünkü tam Düşünme Zamanı
farklılıklarımızı Erdem'e çevirdiğimiz
zaman artık kayıplar kayıp olmaktan
çıkıyor ve hepimiz hayata ilk defa
geliyor Ben diyorum aranızda beni
kincidir geliyorum ben olduğunu
biliyorum diyen varsa bir şey diyemem
ama ben Ve tanıdığım hiçkimse iki defa
gelmedi fizik defa geldik Dolayısıyla
tecrübesiz her şeyi yeni öğreniyoruz
helal hayata ilk geldiğimizde ki
zamanları hatırlarsak hiçbir şey
bilmediğimiz
tecrübesiz olduğumuz zamanları çocukken
hepimiz sırf keyif aldığımız için birçok
şey yapıp merak ettiğiniz için
yapıyorduk sürprizi mutlu ettiği için
yapıyorduk birçok şeyi o zaman başarı
yoktu başarısızlık yoktu kaybetmek yoktu
kazanmak yoktu hiçbir yoktur merak
ediyorduk mutluyduk yapıyorduk gene
ıslak gönder ki bir kitabında aynı
yazardan örnek vereyim
Büyümek fiziksel olarak gelişmek
değildir erginleşmek tirler ve bir Ergin
İçindeki Çocuğu öldürmüş kişi değildir
hayatta kalmayı başarmış bir çocuktur
der gerçekten İçimizdeki Çocuk her
şeyden keyif alan çocuğu kaybetmek
öldürmek lazım merakla saldırmak lazım
kaybediyorsa kaybetti o beyninin
zihnimiz doğası gereği yaşamak için de
deneyerek bazı şeyler emniyete alır ve
otomatik değiştirir Örneğin yürümek
yürürken düşmez ya da açtı çatal kaşıkla
yemek yemek otomatik bir şeyler yemek
yerken ağzımıza dedi diye düşünmeyin
otomatik hareket ederiz Ama bazı şeyler
vardır Bunlar otomatik hareketler
dillerde işte kaybetmek [ __ ] otomatik
hareketlerde
başarısızlıktır gerçekten de toplumlarda
da biraz önce bahsettiğim o
kalabalıklarda da otomatik düşünce
biçimleri vardır komşu teyzeler Ahbap
Amcalar vardır ve size hep güvenli bir
yaşamı tavsiye ederler bu
en yaratıcı düşünce de kaybetmek bir
mecburiyettir ama otomatikleşmiş
davranışlarda da kayıp başarısızlıktır
demiştim ya işte bu amcaların bu
teyzelerin akrabaların son derece
gereksiz tavsiyeleri vardır ama şöyle
yap ama böyle yap riske girmeye derler
hayır öyle değil ton ters Hiç öyle
yapmak lazım Çünkü bir kere geldik dedim
ya bir kere bir kere yok devam öncesinde
yoktu bunları denemek lazım ve o
yaratıcılık dediğimiz kısmı kullanıp
çözüm üretmek lazım Çünkü bugün
teknolojinin medeniyetimizin geldiği
seviye hataların kayıpların tarihi
kayıpların sonucu iz buradayız O
kayıtları olmasaydı bugün bu teknolojik
seviyede bu medeniyet seviyesinde
olmayacaktık
zamanın sonuna geliyorum çok hızlı
anlatmak zorunda kaldım ama şunu
söylemeden geçemeyeceğim
hepiniz çok değerlisiniz demiştim ya
kendinize inanın hem de çok inanın da
başkalarının söyledikleri falan boş
verin ya Böyle kısa hazları kalıcı bir
mutluluğa tercih eden
Şen hevesleri tecrübelere feda etmiş ve
ölüm korkusu gibi kayıp korkusu yaşayan
zihniyetler Den uzak durun Çünkü esas
korkmamız gereken ölüm ya da kayıp değil
deli gibi korkuyoruz ama korktuğumuz
şeydadır sonra korkuyorlar onların
korktuğu şey Başkaları ne der korkusu
bundan da korkmayın Başkaları ne
diyeceğini hiç önemli değil Esas
korkmanız gereken şey şu bir gün
gerçekler karşımıza çıkıp yaşadıklarının
tamamı bir hayat yapmaz derse İşte o
zaman nokta koymuştur o zaman Gerçekten
kayıptır başarısızlıktır bunu denemek
lazım kendinize inanın çok inanın ve
sadece kazanacağını zamanı düşünün
kaybetmektende vazgeçmeyin beğendiğiniz
için teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]